good afternoon everybody thank you
whether it's corporate email
collaboration tools for remote workers
barcode scanners for logistics workers
or stock market tickers for finance
types there's a whole world of Apps for
work out there now with Android for work
you can focus on making great apps for
business and with Google Play for work
you can make apps available to the whole
workforce so with your apps of work we
can all be productive while we're mobile
my name is James Kelly and I'm a product
manager on the Android team last year we
launched Android for work as a way for
IT admins to deploy devices and apps to
their employees and keep corporate data
safe and secure now today we're
announcing we're expanding Android for
work to cover new kinds of devices and
apps and make it simpler to grow the
audience for your apps to all kinds of
businesses and I'm Matt goodwitch a
product manager on the Google Play team
at Google Play for work our mission is
to reduce the barriers for developers
such as yourselves to get innovative
apps discovered and used by businesses
while keeping the businesses data safe
and secure Hey and I'm Richard Hyndman
developer advocate on the Android team
helping to make sure you guys have all
the materials you need to build great
applications but also taking feedback
from you and taking it to the guys
making the products like James and Matt
did you know that according to Gartner
businesses globally spent a hundred and
forty three billion dollars on
application software in 2015 across
desktop and mobile just to put that in
perspective that is 25 percent bigger
than the entire global spend on video
games across all platforms in the same
year an apps targeted at mobile devices
are by far the growers the fastest
growing business segment that there is
so but compared to the gaming industry
business apps are much further behind in
moving to mobile devices in part that is
because of the lack of developers taking
advantage of this opportunity
in fact Gartner says that demand for
business apps will outstrip development
reach by five to one
that's me pretty exciting news for you
guys it means we're early in an exciting
revolution in business software and
developers were already starting to see
success let's look at some examples
DocuSign launched his signature business
knowing it would need to appeal to both
consumers who needed to sign and return
documents on the go and businesses who
saw tremendous value in making every
decision approval workflow and signature
100% digital they recently said that 99%
of mobile revenue comes from businesses
sending documents to obtain approvals
and signatures to transact business
faster and consumers help expose
businesses to DocuSign because signing
and returning and occupant is always
free
it's an incredible viral network that
drives revenue growth Dropbox started as
a file sync and share solution for
consumers but the number of Dropbox
business customers has grown globally
three and a half times in the past two
years there were 200 million unique
mobile devices connected to Dropbox last
year cool thanks man so it's clear
there's a huge opportunity in business
app development
so why develop on Android let's look at
this from the perspective of an IT admin
now often businesses require a range of
both internally and externally develop
apps and those apps have to work across
multiple platforms so to manage all of
that complexity IT will often partner
with a supplier of the enterprise
mobility management or an EMM now with
Android for work we work with some of
the top EMM partners like those you see
here and we've worked with other
developers OMS and carriers to make
their products great for business now
businesses can choose the solution
that's right for them because Android is
an open platform these solutions cover a
wide range of business needs so in
addition to this variety of apps IT also
need to offer different kinds of devices
for different use cases
now since Android supports a really
diverse range of devices at all kinds of
price points as a
platform it's a great tool to give IT
the choices they need to mobilize the
entire workforce so I know many of you
will be familiar with Android for work
but for those of you that aren't let's
describe a little bit about what we do
so first there's BYOD entré forks a
great option for bringing your own
device now organizations allow employees
to bring their favorite Android device
for work to work with Android for where
employees can use the devices they want
but get the apps they need this works by
the business is able to create a secure
work profile on the device where work
apps and data reside and these are
securely managed by the IT department
data in the work profile is kept safe
and separate so the business can protect
against data loss but at the same time
the employee can be confident that a
company can't access personal data or
activity now next Android for work has a
model we call device owner if a business
prefers to give employees fully managed
devices with access to the most secure
corporate systems
that's what device owners for in do the
company owns the whole device and
manages manages the data on it IT has
complete control over the entire device
which may mean for example that the user
can only use apps that are approved by
IT and finally there's cosu
corporate-owned single-use devices this
is a very diverse range of business
needs you may want to manage a fleet of
devices that are used for a single
purpose for example like a kiosk kosu
devices are typically deployed where the
device is locked to a single or a small
number of apps and this mode gives the
company confidence the device cannot be
used for anything else even if for
example it's a kiosk in a public place
we've built comprehensive data policy
controls into Android that ensure
company data is safe while it's on the
mobile device for example blocking
screen capture or stopping content being
copied for my work app into a personal
app you can find out more about all of
these controls at developer.android.com
slash work we're sending the link to the
event space now security is a critical
aspect of any mobile platform in a
workplace the Android security team is
raising the bar on Android security you
can see more details in the year-end
review that we published back in April
and if you missed Adrienne Ludwig's talk
on Adrienne on Android security this
morning you can catch up with it on
YouTube all that Android security is or
is is pushing the boundaries with things
like androids
monthly security patch updates and much
much more we're posting the link to the
video and the report to the event space
right now
and finally app management Google Play
for work enables an administrator to
authorize employees to use apps on their
work device or work profile or push
install those apps remotely and
configure them these controls are
exposed to the administrator through the
business's emm console and to the user
through the Play Store app on the device
we'll see examples of these shortly but
let's go back to James to find out
what's new in Android M cool thanks Matt
so I think we're all clear on what
Android for work is now and as you know
we're constantly making improvements and
investments in in the platform so last
year businesses told us they wanted
better security and more controls for IT
admins and users told us they wanted a
better user experience and a better
work-life work-life balance so in the
end developer preview we've expanded on
those things with a range of new
capabilities in Android first off if you
were there what's new in Android n talk
yesterday EULA scene chat talked about
this feature it's a great feature
to enhance security and control over
corporate data we call it the work
challenge so work challenge is a
separate passcode that protects work
apps and data on a BYOD device so this
means that IT no longer needs to set
complex password requirements for the
device lock screen which get in the way
instead they can except they can set a
passcode requirement that only applies
to work apps and they have policies
around how often they can show that
password requirement and so on and so
forth we also added file based
encryption and fast secure wipe-on
supported devices so when an employee
switches devices corporate data is never
compromised
another long requested feature is always
on VPN so we've added always-on VPN to
the platform incidentally this works for
both consumer and business apps so now a
business can route all data traffic from
work apps to their VPN from boot up to
shutdown now because the system can
directly bind VPN services without
interaction VPN clients need to handle
some new entry points on the device for
example at boot up as the system service
will start the VPN so if you build a VPN
app you need to bear this in mind
you'll also need to ensure that you can
support user configuration of the
always-on capability in your apps UI to
help you with that there are some open
source X samples or using Open VPN
available on github and we're going to
add a link to that in the event space
now so alongside our always-on vpm we've
made some additional improvements in to
work contacts to better integrate them
into the system dialer messenger and
contacts app so this lets you search
across work and personal contacts
seamlessly from those apps and for
example if you've got a call from a
colleague in the call log
that'll resolve and show you the
colleagues name rather than just a
number we've also improved transparency
in the system UI so you always know when
your device might be affected by your IT
departments policy we also allow for
example IT to set a support message
directly in the system UI to provide our
links to support resources
now users often tell us they love having
the option of separate apps for work and
personal tasks but are there times when
you would love to detach from work so
we've added a feature we call work mode
to Android now work mode lets you
control work apps from quick settings
you can shut them all down at the top of
the briefcase icon in quick settings
when you're in work mode work and
personal apps run side by side but
outside of work map mode work apps don't
run they don't generate interruptions
they don't consume battery and they
don't consume data so it's like an off
switch for work how cool is that and
there's a full list of features in the
end Developer Preview documentation we
have added over 20 features into into
the Android and release for business and
we're adding a link to those features
into the event space now if you need to
evaluate the full range of capabilities
in Android we encourage you to download
our EMM Developer focused app called
test DPC from play so test device policy
client functions as a profile owner or a
device owner with local controls over
policy so this lets you set policy and
restrictions locally without needing
like an enterprise server of in the
cloud to configure the device and if
you'd like to test your app for
compatibility with android for work it's
a really great tool for that so by
listening to feedback from IT and making
these improvements in Android n we hope
we've made Android an even better
solution for business be sure to install
the N Developer Preview if you haven't
already and check out features like work
mode so you could enjoy that vacation on
the beach free of interruptions from the
office so how can you get started with
Android for work as a developer you need
to know that your app will work for all
kinds of businesses so to do that we're
gonna give you a sneak peek of a new way
to get set up with a fully functioning
work profile so you can test apps for
work on your own device or you can use
this to set up a work profile for a
clean separation between your work and
personal lives
now in our example I want you to imagine
I'm a marketing manager at an aquatic
supply company called happy guppy
alongside the productivity apps
I want my sales team to use show pad to
show a glossy interactive magazine style
brochure to prospective customers I want
all my sales team to have it and I want
them up and running quickly and not have
to search for an app and maybe configure
it or log into it let's switch to the
Chromebook please first let's get set up
on the web now playful work allows IT to
pre-approve apps or make a range of
optional apps available on your device
so rich let's go ahead and improve show
pad
cool that's done now show pads approved
proving approved we need to switch to
now we need to set up users in our new
business think of this is just like IT
would do when I'm boarding a new
employee for example so rich is gonna
hit go ahead and create a user now after
rich does this will be prompted to
switch to our device and download an app
that'll be used to manage it we're gonna
do that in a sec but here is the cool
thing we've simplified set up into one
step trying out android for work on your
device is as simple as scanning a QR
code don't scan it won't work
so now let's switch to our device
alright so first that's gonna find the
android for work app which will guide us
through setup see there's a wizard in
here and he's gonna scan the QR code now
after scanning the QR code a work
profile is set up for work apps and data
now just as a reminder the work profile
is a secure space that's managed by your
employer but of course in this case the
employer is you so you're kind of
self-employed I guess so apps that are
available to employees are shown in a
separate play for work store as well as
push install of pre-approved apps admins
are able to put a range of optional apps
into the Play for work store for an
employee to install later now finally on
a BYOD device
we place a badge on work apps
notifications as well or badged and
recents are badged with the briefcase
logo this is to help distinguish them
from your personal apps so after the
secure the point is here this is all of
the setup for android for work has been
simplified into that single step
no more having to enter obscure
usernames and passwords our navigate
through confusing screens in this case
we built a set up token into the QR code
but other mechanisms are possible for
example there's no QR reader on the
device will fall back to a one-time wolf
code so hopefully after a few moments
our work profile is set up this work
profile is a separate space for caps and
data and the key here is that in a real
android for work deployment IT only
controls this space and not the entire
device so after setup is complete you'll
see work apps on the device in a work
profile initially it contains a few
badge system utilities in the Play for
work store the work cups are badged and
organized into a work folder in the
Google launcher and the show pad app
that we approved is being automatically
installed now from the cloud from Google
Play for work while that's happening
let's hope the Wi-Fi holds up switch
back to slides please so we're gonna be
launching this new way to set up android
for work on your device later this year
you'll be able to create a fully
functioning work profile with playful
work in it on supported devices which
include those running marshmallow and of
course the end Developer Preview you can
use the web console to simulate the way
an IT department would deploy and manage
apps and set policies on your device
it's a great way for developers and IT
admins to evaluate Android for work for
their organization with no extra setup
required you just can use this so for
now you can visit our sandbox area where
we've got some of these devices set up
and some of our engineering team is on
hand to show you this and other demos in
some more detail so how does Google help
you get your app to businesses by
publishing your app through Google Play
your app is automatically enrolled to be
distributed to businesses through Google
Play for work as you just saw in the
demo when an administrator wants to
deploy your app at scale to their users
the administrator
makes sure that the users are set up for
mobile management selects your app in
the management console and the group of
users they want to deploy it to and in
one click your app gets deployed to all
of those users devices this gives you
another route to getting users versus
trying to get them one by one as if they
were consumers now let's move on to how
to make your app really awesome for
businesses some of the biggest
challenges that we've heard from
business customers and developers are
app customization configuration and
single sign-on how do you make your app
behave differently for different
customers and still maintain one apk how
do you enable business users to get
started with your app with minimum
manual configuration how do you ensure
that business customers incur minimum
support costs when running your app
we're going to cover two things that
will help you address that first of all
customization and configuration of your
app and in secondly integrating business
single sign-on with your app you can
allow administrators to remotely
customize and configure your app in
Android for work by allowing a
configuration bundle to be sent down to
your app in a schema that you the
developer define what's really unique
about android for work is the way we
deliver that configuration down to the
device later on this year we're going to
be allowing configuration to be sent
through Google Play for work rather than
the EMM directly on the device Google
Play ensures that that configuration
bundle lands on the device at the same
time as install in an atomic operation
ensuring a seamless experience for the
user and that the schema of the config
bundle matches the version of the app
that's being installed so let's start
look looking at how manage configuration
can help you let's say you're the
developer of the to doing app which you
distribute to individual users through
Google Play you only want to maintain
one apk but your customers want to
customize your app for example they want
to make it corporate colors or put their
logo on it including in the loadings
you can set up configuration parameters
for foreground and background colors a
URL for the logo and if your app loads
without the config eg on individuals
device downloaded on the consumer Play
Store your app defaults to your regular
experience if the config is available
you can customize the experience from
the first time the app launches you
still maintain just one apk so what is
this magic for app developers app
configurations are just like app
restrictions that came in in jellybean
although this time it's IT admins during
the configuration and not parents your
app can support any configurations that
you want you just have to define them in
an XML file like this the restriction
type there we have a string but there's
lots of different options of integer
multiple choice pooling other things and
then you refer to that restrictions file
with all the separate restrictions you
want to specify in your Android manifest
and it's pretty much that easy it's
easier than adding a preferences screen
into your application because the rest
of the heavy lifting is done by the EMS
and the Google Play API is the EMM is go
and read these configurations using the
API is straight from your XML files from
our servers and then the EMS offer up
configuration screens to IT admins the
IT admins can then go and set in
corporate logos login hints whatever
they need to do and then in your
application you just use the
restrictions manager just like you would
with Pat restrictions and called get
application restrictions when you call
this you'll get that bundle of
restrictions down that the IT admins
have set through the EMM consoles that
they're used to using anyway so it
really is easier than putting a
preference to screen in your application
and you can move all that logic out and
let IT admins set preferences for users
instead also you going to want to listen
out for for a broadcast on the system
there's a broadcast action applications
restriction changed which is harder to
say but IT admins can change these
things at any time so you listen for the
broadcast and if they change it once you
have already installed you'll get that
broadcast with the new bundle and you
can change whatever the IT admins change
it's the VPN location on anything thanks
rich so many let's move on now to look
at single sign-on so many companies use
web single sign-on allowing their users
to access all company software and
resources using single username and
password single sign-on has long been a
feature of web-based services but
getting it to work on a mobile device
has been pretty challenging until now
architectures vary but let's focus on
the most common case where you have a
SAS back-end for your app which might
also have a web component and that your
customer is using an enterprise
authorization server to manage all of
their single sign-on an app
authorization what typically happens
today is that the user is first prompted
to identify or identify themselves with
some kind of identifier this is often
the company email address but it course
also be the company name this helps the
app resolve the identity provider that
the company is using via its ass
back-end and then the app then presents
the login screen for the identity
provider where the user enters their
user name again and their password
before getting to the app and then if I
install another app I have to go through
the same thing again and again
ouch wouldn't it be great if the if SSO
on mobile just worked like it did on the
web if the user has already logged in
with their SSO credentials on their
device then all I have to do is accept
an OAuth permissions prompt once and
even then they don't have to do that if
they've already accepted it on another
device we're going to go through how to
get this ideal SSO flow in your app
there are two stages firstly we're going
to use manage configuration to tell your
app which SSO provider to use and then
pre populate the user name secondly
we're going to use a new feature in
Android called chrome custom tabs to go
together with the app off library to
persist the user's login state across
apps
let's start with a managed configuration
you need to create a field in man in
manage configuration called login hint
which your app can send to its SAS
back-end which will help it resolve the
identity provider if you've implemented
web SSO then this should sound pretty
familiar let's see how this login hint
field should be used so the
administrator is going to be using the
emm console to configure the at your
android app will send the login hint in
the configuration bundle down when your
app first loads it sends the OAuth
request to your SAS back-end it contains
also sends down that login hint
so the SAS back-end can then resolve the
which Enterprise authentication server
to use then depending on which
technology have used whether it's a Worf
whether it's sam'l or whether it's open
ID connect you can communicate to the
server and then present the login screen
to the user so that's the initial signup
flow now let's use a persistent login
session with chrome custom tabs first of
all let's take a look at what chrome
custom tabs are it's a secure context
where you can show any webpage but the
host app can't inspect the contents the
user can see the server address but they
can't edit it and the cookie state is
shared with any other custom tab and
Chrome browser itself this is what's
going to give you that persistent login
state it's a system browser activity
presented in the app context so you
don't need to worry about users being
redirected between different contexts it
ships in chrome 45 and supports all
devices back to jelly bean chrome chips
with every device with the Play Store so
it will be there if your user if your
users device defaults to a different
browser that doesn't support custom tabs
then chrome may still be available you
don't actually need to integrate with
Google accounts this is just an example
by the way so using the app earth
library from open ID
you can very quickly build your auth
step which will directly show the
customer's identity provider login
screen if the user is not yet signed in
on the device if the enterprise or
server is configured to pass the
username from the login hint to the
identity provider then it will be
pre-populated as well and if the user
has already signed in to their account
then they go straight in no username and
password at all how easy is that
pretty easy rich thanks very much so you
can simplify the SSO in your application
making lives easier for users and IT
admins and the best bit about it is
there's a library available for both
Android and iOS that's going to do all
the heavy lifting for you it speaks both
a wealth to and open ID connect and as
convenience methods to assist with
common tasks like performing actions
with a fresh token as matt says it'll
use chrome custom tabs which has access
to that shared cookie jar so it's just
going to work and if chrome custom tabs
isn't available it falls back to the
system browser if you just lose that
in-app branding that you'd get so you
can head over to github comm slash open
ID and there's an a a are there for
Android so you can drop it in your
project but there's also it's also in
maven central so you can stick it in
your Gradle file you've got the
dependency and you can get up and
running with the new SSO flows embedded
inside your applications also as Matt
mentioned you're going to want to use
that log in here are people already
doing SSO foes and a war with login
hints people nodding one two yeah quite
a few okay so for the app restriction
for login hints exactly the same as
before just give the IT admins that item
in their console by putting this XML in
your your application so they can add a
login hint that gets driven down to your
application and then your auth flow is
much more simple great thanks rich so
that's the theory but let's have a look
at it on a on a real app in a real
device so let's switch to the demo
thank you so we're going to go back to
show pad which we installed earlier but
first of all I'm going to show you show
pads running in a consumer profile so
you can see the difference and the
experience so I
already installed show pad here just
from the consumer Play Store it launches
with a warm welcome telling me which
features it's got and then I can either
log in or try a demo I'm gonna log in it
first asked me for my organization name
so this is this identifier that I
mentioned before so I'm going to type in
Google let's hope my fat fingers work
and then I've got my my email address so
I need to put that in and wrong so never
mind right we'll just do that make sure
it was good afternoon and the password
right so but if I'm a busy sales guy I
don't want to have to set up every app
like this so let's take a look at what
it looks like if it's pre-configured
with managed configuration so I'm going
to go back to the version show pad that
we pre installed earlier which is in the
work profile I start off with the same
warm welcome showing me what features
but once I'm through that the only thing
I can do is login so I'm going to go and
log in and then it's automatically seen
the scene the company name and it's
showing me my username there as well
so I know which user name I'm logging in
as and then I can recall which passwords
to get started with okay back to slides
peace sweet
so I've had the app push to my sales
teams to devices and pre-configured for
them saving them time and brainpower and
giving them more time to spend with our
customers as a developer you can alter
the behavior of your app based on
configuration that can be customized on
a per customer per user or even a per
device basis you should also be aware of
an industry standardization effort
called app config community which was
initiated by a group of leading
enterprise mobility management partners
app config is working with developers
and mobile platforms and others in the
ecosystem to come up with some common
best practices on configuring apps in a
business environment Google is working
with app config to further evolve the
app configuration for the benefit of the
entire ecosystem and they've recently
unveiled their initial Android guidance
in collaboration with Google so check it
out we're posting a link to the event
space now thanks about I hope you're all
gonna go off and could provision manage
configuration now we're all familiar
with the kind of devices we carry every
day they're great for fun and
productivity and selfies but beyond that
there is a huge range of Android devices
suitable for a diverse range of
workplaces so just look in the world
around you and wherever you see a
clipboard there's actually an amazing
opportunity for a good Android app
experience now we partnered with a group
of OMS including honeywell zebra or
zebra Kia Sarah and Panasonic to bring a
range of these Android devices to the
wider workplace all these devices
feature tough external cases and a
barcode scanning capability so that
perfect for use in the field and we have
heard from many customers that they want
to deploy manage Android devices in
logistics retail construction sectors
and so we've invested in making Android
for work a really great platform
to do that and now we're asking our
developers to build amazing app
experiences for what we call cosu
corporate-owned single-use devices so
what could a kosu app look like here's
one possibility now we all love the
convenience of shopping from home and if
you're anything like me you order
everything from groceries to gifts from
the comfort of your couch in fact Matt
told me his guppy fish was feeling a bit
down and as this real screenshot from
Matt's house shows he decided to order
his guppy a new pal now I'm sure most of
us don't think about how our latest
purchase makes its way to us android for
work makes it a breeze for companies
like happy guppy to set up a manage a
fleet of devices so all of their
delivery drivers have the apps they need
in the palm of their hand first I T will
set up the fleet of kosu devices and
there are a number of ways to do this
but from a brand-new out-of-the-box
device setting up android for work is as
simple as an NFC bump and in the n
Developer Preview we've added fast setup
using QR codes into the setup wizard -
once the devices have been set up they
can be locked down so that only app for
all apps authorized by IT are accessible
in the launcher so in this way by
combining apps for barcode scanning with
apps for scheduling and apps like maps
for navigation with their employee and
delivery database in the cloud
happy guppy drivers can use a single
kosu device for the job and when the
driver reaches Matt's house they can use
the barcode scanning app to record the
delivery they can get a signature or
maybe even a photo if they've left the
package in a safe place or unsafe place
and make Matt a happy happy guppy
customer so whether it's running a
single app on a dedicated device
or optimizing the entire and to an
experience for a mobile workforce you
can develop great apps for mobile
workers IT can use playful work to keep
them up to date as well you know Matt
I've gone a different way with the
interior yeah but it looks like Matt's
guppy loves his new power so how would
you build a great kosu app to give you
some pointers let's welcome back rich to
show you how okay so for a co-ceo app
you've got three main points first of
all you've got the device owner the
device owner is going to go on the
device and allow IT admins to remotely
own that device that's really important
because you don't want the user of the
device to have to configure it at all
then you're gonna have an NFC
provisioning app the NFC provisioning
app you bump with the device when it's
in its setup wizard and it transfers the
data for that device owner to be
installed and then you've got your
single-use device in this case the happy
guppy delivery drivers application so
here I'll show you how to get the NFC
app and the device owner app in a minute
but once you've got the NFC app you give
it some configurations and these
configurations when you bump it with the
with the single-use device are the
things that are sent over to the setup
wizard so in our case we've got this
list of URLs check sums and package
names they're going to go over during
the NFC bump onto the device and the
device in the setup wizard is going to
download the device owner install it and
the device own up we'll set policies on
that device the first thing it's going
to do is go and find our Co Co app which
is also passed in here this is our happy
guppy app and it will then also install
that application they then adds it to a
whitelist of applications that can run
as kiosk applications which is why I've
got the package name at the bottom so if
you want to try it out for yourself and
we'll show you the demo of this in a
second you can just go into either
Android studio and go to import samples
and type in device admin and you'll see
we've got a few samples but the bottom
two NFC provisioning a device owner are
the ones we're using so you've actually
got the NFC provisioning app for
creating a Coastie device and the device
owner app which goes on as the policy
client which owns the device
you can also go to our github google
samples github repo they're always
always available there as well so in the
happy guppy case you need to set your
kiosk app that delivery driver app into
full-screen mode and to do that you've
got the start lock task and stop lock
task api's that came in before I think
they came in jelly bean okay if you use
those it pins the app to the device in
full screen but there's use the consent
dialogs and they usually come back out
with device owner if you're on this lock
task whitelist it will go into full
screen and the user can never get back
out of it again you'll see those demo
kiosks we've got over on the android for
work sandbox it's just a full screen
kiosk device so you want to build a
backdoor for yourself whilst you're
developing else you man with a very
single-use device you can never get back
out of it's expensive development that
could be expensive $500 device 500 in
our case when we were developing we've
got this barcode scanner from Honeywell
we have an admin barcode and if you scan
that admin barcode it drops back out of
single use mode call stop lock task
drops out and then you can reset your
device or do what you need to do with it
so as a developer there's a couple of
things to consider first single-use
devices first of all you're gonna want
sorry single-use applications you're
gonna want your application to be
entirely self-contained you know what I
owned that user journey if you're a
hotel kiosk app you're going to not want
to let the user somehow click a link and
get into a web browser and then just
start browsing the web on your hotel
kiosk you're going to want to keep them
in the room booking system so so you
have a web view like a web site you want
to link to put it in a web view or a
chrome custom tab and own the entire
experience if you do need to link out to
other apps you're defining kind of a
multi app kosu system and you'll have to
figure out the entry points and exit
points or maybe just decide that you're
going to want to have a launcher and
have a slightly more complex system you
can still have launches on single-use
devices if you want to so we have that
test DPC app that James mentioned
earlier and you can go to Google samples
as well and get the test DPC app to test
all the android for work features out
but feuless it's not all that
complicated if you're just getting into
the mindset of being a single use
application developer so let's see it in
action
so
here is an example of a device from
Honeywell
that's great for a mobile workforce it's
a rugged device running marshmallow that
features a built-in laser scanner and
that's just what we need to get our
guppy his new pal how could this work
for real using an app for work
rich we better get em where's James
let's do we get the wolf vision to
protect ya let's go to the ball fishin
ok so this is the laser scanning
ruggedized honeywell marshmallow machine
that we'll be using today and it's just
factory reset on the setup wizard so to
show how easy it is to jinx the demo I'm
gonna NFC bump it and turn it into
delivery driver application now now this
is just like what the IT a team would do
when they're setting up devices for
their workforce just sayin sorry oh
sorry during setup on the the left here
we have the programming device see now
once setup of the Honeywell device is
completed you'll see we're landed right
into our starting screen now during
setup device owner is set and this is an
important step because it means the
device can only be managed by beat by IT
and the IT can set appropriate security
policies to govern device and app usage
so you'll see we're all set up and ready
to go as simple as that wasn't that fast
now we need to I think load up on
packages and hit the streets right get
my delivery driver going on I should
have turned it in that beforehand what
happened first in our demo app is that
rich will scan his employee ID badge ok
so I scan this with their lovely laser
scanner there we go we've got delivery
details for his various packages in the
demo app we've integrated navigation
using Google Maps right into the
launcher app so that he can use Google
Maps to safely navigate along the
optimal route now devices like this are
now shipping with google apps like map
since
so as a developer you can be sure that
navigation is available on the device oh
look his delivery is right on the
Googleplex how about that
now once rich arrives he can drop off
his package and get a signature there we
go oh wow cool as an employee rich can't
break out of this mode so there's no
risk of confusion and support costs are
reduced and the device can be remotely
administered by IT using a wide range of
Android api's
such as for example being able to
remotely reboot and manage the device so
you're gonna scan for delivery yep so if
I go and scan the package thank you I
get a signature okay you can all see
Matt and Matt look so happy okay as you
can see we've got the signature and
Matt's guppy has a cool new friend using
Android good reiterate that was
provisioning an entire single-use device
from start to end doing a delivery in
about a minute now this is just one
example of an app for work optimized for
kosu device but there are many many more
from retail to hospitality to healthcare
we're only just getting started so are
you are ready to seize the opportunity
to make a difference to an entire
workforce remember how Google and
Android can help you and what it is easy
to set up for businesses it's fast for
businesses to deploy your app at scale
with Google Play for work and you can
make apps awesome for businesses by
allowing them to be customized and
configured and use SSO as slickly as on
the web Android is ready for business
now let's go build apps for it join us
for the public launch of our Android for
work developer community called dev hub
where there are loads of resources for
work app developers thank you